make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with infinite crisis and lord
knows it took us long enough to finish
this thing so many vacations and so many
trips so in the last video that we did
we basically talked about how darkseid
was seemingly the the guy behind
everything that was going on with
regards to the current multiversal
situation at least an infinite frontier
and to a degree that's true what we're
actually going to find out in this story
is that there is someone behind darkseid
doing what it is that he's doing but
what we end up doing here is basically
picking up with a kind of coming
together of the various heroes right the
multiversal justice league now again i
would highly suggest that you go back
and watch our playlist in order to get
caught up on everything going on with
dark crisis specifically infinite
frontier and again you'll find that
playlist down in the description but the
thing behind this is you basically have
this kind of statement made by darkseid
that once the flash cracks through their
multiverse then he'll have access or at
least dark side will have access to what
lies beyond which is essentially a key
or at least a huge amount of power that
is not readily available and in fact the
whole purpose behind roy harper being
here and being the omega lantern is that
he is the way in which darkseid can
access and use that source of energy now
of course because this is a conclusion
this is things wrapping up fairly fast
which actually works better for us
because it gives us the ability to offer
huge explanations on what's going on
which we're going to need by the time we
get to this so of course you do end up
having obsidian who basically rescues
roy harper now obsidian has the ability
to manipulate darkness that's kind of
the basis behind his power but that
right there in and of itself gives me a
reason to believe that obsidian is going
to become exceedingly important over the
course of dark crisis itself and then
you also have the flash now one of the
things was interesting about this is
that barry allen was being used much in
the same way that he was during the
original crisis on infinidus event in
the sense that he was powering the
machine that was being used to basically
wipe out the multiverse it's very
similar here except in this instance
he's kind of serving a different purpose
which is to basically create a crack in
the multiverse right the the means by
which dark side can access what's on the
other side now you do have machine head
machine head was basically the traitor
among justice incarnate he was the one
that really kind of led them all here
but machine head was only one part of
this whole situation in the sense that
what you had is various people who had
come to this realization by one
situation or another you effectively had
like worlds that were ending you had
crisis events different things like that
but they were always stemming from the
main dc universe machine head is by all
standards of measurement just part of a
faction that has allied themselves with
dark side for the purpose of essentially
restarting wiping away redoing the
multiverse and that's one of the things
to know is that what dark crisis is
doing seems to be basically eliminating
or
really just kind of removing the
significance of like dark nights metal
and all that kind of stuff right that
crisis event because the funny thing
about this is looking at it for what it
is you know dark nights metal death
metal all that kind of stuff that was
kind of an unofficial crisis right it
was a giant story that dealt with the
batman who laughs but whether it was the
intention of dc or not it essentially
rewrote a lot of the stuff that we know
about the multiverse what seems to be
going on with this is that dc's either
going back and consolidating all that
information or just doing away with it
entirely which is just kind of weird
it's dc literally undoing what they just
did what's the point right but of course
you do have a president superman who
basically rescues the flash which in the
moment stops the campaign of darkseid
because that's really what they're
shooting for here right they see
darkseid as the prime threat and the
reality is that he's not but because
they don't know that their goal is to
simply stop what darkseid's doing and
they succeed right and in fact flash
actually ends up out in the uh out in
the multiverse somewhere we'll find out
where he goes once we get to the end of
this but it essentially stops what it
was that dark side was doing right it
ends darkseid's campaign right there
darkseid essentially chimes in and is
like we are all doomed right he says
like the ring has gone out the flash is
gone the crack is lost the omniverse has
been taken from me and then of course he
turns on psycho pirate who was basically
the guy that was manipulating barry
allen and forcing him to believe that he
was actually running alongside the other
flashes to save the multiverse now ever
the escape artist a psycho pirate
basically ends up getting out of there
right he literally just teleports away
just takes off and then of course you
have machine head kind of wrapping up
little plot threads here machine head is
the one that steps up and tries to take
the place of psycho pirate and is
ultimately destroyed by dark side using
his omega beans and then of course once
you have like the other members of the
justice incarnate who show up here for
the the attempt to try to stop darkseid
he basically freezes them in place and
then teleports them back to their base
of operations and then you do get a
little bit of a of maybe not really an
epilogue but kind of people figuring out
where they are now and what's going on
but the important thing here and this is
really the the significant takeaway from
the entirety of infinite frontier we
switch over to really switch back to
earth omega and you have the omega ring
that's given to cameron chase from an
alternate reality also operating under
the name extract and darkseid asked the
question he says they don't understand
what we unlocked today are you ready to
bow to me will you not fail me like
psychopirate did and cameron chase joins
him and asks and she literally says but
i have to ask why did you let them all
live and the response of dark side is
because the heroes of the multiverse
will play a role in the coming wars just
as my family will but that needs to be
left in the past and he says i have
brought you all here so you can
understand what is at stake earth omega
was never a world it is a piece of a
resting enemy dormant since the first
crisis and now it wakes we will find the
flash and the crack in the omniverse i
am not the only one who seeks this power
but only i will control the great
darkness now this is a massive
revelation by dc comics and here's the
reason why right this is where we make
sense of everything so in this instance
where you're looking at this page and
you have the guy with the horns coming
out of his head that's the empty hand
right like empty is my hand that's kind
of his thing uh that guy is immensely
powerful the great darkness is more
powerful than he is so one of the things
to know here and this is kind of a
general concept a general explanation
when it comes to this the great darkness
is the antithesis to the presence and i
know a lot of people will say no no no
isn't that supposed to be lucifer not
really remember lucifer is just a fallen
angel right he's an angel that
challenged the power of god and was
condemned to hell for all eternity as a
result of that and they just can't you
know god and satan have kind of been
feuding back and forth but in reality
the relationship between god and satan
is based more on morality than anything
else right god represents pure goodness
and satan represents what it means to be
what it means to turn against god in
effect the reality here is that when god
said let there be light and basically
brought light into all existence
essentially created everything the great
darkness basically existed before that
so if god represents absolute good the
great darkness represents absolute evil
it's the antithesis of god like if there
were an evil version of god that was
equal to god in power that's what the
great darkness essentially is now one of
the things to know is that in the
original crisis event and the way the
whole great darkness played out it
didn't really have a concept of what it
was it didn't really understand things
like good and evil and so on and so
forth it wasn't until you started
getting into like the constantine
stories and things like that that the
concept of evil was introduced to the
great darkness things along those lines
and it basically took on this role of
being the actual antithesis of god right
the opposite of god uh because of that
the great darkness has always just sort
of lingered out there but in truth we
hadn't heard about it for quite some
time now one thing to know it is an
immutable and indestructible force it
cannot actually be defeated but beyond
that the fact that the empty hand is
here is also a huge thing because during
grant morrison's multiversity stories
right parts one and two i'm pretty sure
we covered both of those and if we did
we'll include that in the playlist if we
didn't we do have a beyond omega level
video on the empty hand which we'll
include as well it'll basically give you
a pretty good understanding of what the
character is about he only ever really
appeared in those stories and the
multiversity stories that's when he was
created uh the truth is that the empty
hand is basically the right hand of the
great darkness right so if the great
darkness is this antithesis of god then
the empty hand does the bidding of the
great darkness and the great darkness is
exactly what it sounds like right it
seeks to to control consume and destroy
things but this all really comes to
fruition when you have the really kind
of picking up with barry allen and barry
allen basically being whisked away to
what is perceived to be another place in
the multiverse only for that to not be
the case that when he crash lands in
this location
what he sees is just like this stream of
worlds ascending into oblivion and he
doesn't initially know what it is he
recognizes it to a degree he's like i've
seen this place before you know during
the original crisis on event earth event
and then ultimately we have this kind of
voice that comes out of nowhere and says
this is multiverse 2 right it was what
came before destroyed by the
anti-monitor in the first crisis the
empty hand and the gentry fed on it for
years it was my fault it's ruined
started with me they made me watch as
each world was swallowed in darkness i
tried to warn them but they would not
listen they could have stopped it but
they didn't you have no idea what that
does to a person right and the reality
here is this person speaking is pariah
now this is where we get to the other
part of the explanation that's why we
kind of rush through the the conclusion
because in all honesty this is more
interesting and more important so one of
the things to know is that the the way
the original crisis on infinite earth
event started is basically
pariah wanting to perceive or wanting to
understand the nature of everything in
doing so he had basically woken up the
anti-monitor and when that happened it
started the anti-monitors campaign
across the multiverse to basically
destroy everything in the positive
multiverse leaving only antimatter so it
was really because of the actions of
pariah that basically the anti-monitor
was unleashed in the first place and as
a result of that pariah was actually
given his name he actually had a name
before but he was given the name pariah
by the original monitor you know because
he was the harbinger of death for the
multiverse right he was literally an
outsider a pariah somebody who was
unwanted because of what it was that he
had done now following the events of
crisis on infinite earth going into the
new universe landscape which is to say
there was only one universe and no
multiverse the reality is that dc never
really knew what to do with pariah and
that was a thing that continued on even
going into like infinite crisis and you
know zero hour crisis in time final
crisis and the truth about this is that
you ended up having this situation
unfold where ultimately uh pariah just
kind of
lingered out there but what this does is
it reintroduces him back to his previous
role where somewhere along the line he
seems to have been snatched back to
multiverse 2 and he's just been here
watching all these worlds being consumed
and destroyed and in fact what he ends
up doing because the fact that he has
the ability to jump through realities
and in fact send other people to
realities he basically seems to trap the
flash inside one of these alternate
earths which is almost indicative of the
way things looked pre-crisis right he's
literally on a pre-crisis world and
that's the important thing to know here
is because the way things unfolded after
the original crisis on infinite earth's
event that as far as we were aware the
original multiverse was destroyed it was
gone there was there was no trace of it
having ever existed in the first place
outside of those individual heroes who
survived its destruction and continued
on in the new earth singular universal
landscape that did not have a multiverse
now in infinite crisis the multiverse
did come back but it was a different
multiverse so think of it as like
multiverse 2.0 as opposed to multiverse
1.0 which was destroyed during crisis
undefended us it's how it is that dc
justified there being a return to a
multiverse but things were just a little
bit different than they originally were
and it stayed that way right it just
continued on that way even going into
the new 52 and has maintained itself
during the new 52 now some of those
things have shifted some of those things
have changed a little bit to a degree
right but for the most part it all still
kind of remains intact what we're being
told here is that unlike what we were
initially told during crisis infinites
multiverse 1.0 was never destroyed it
was never eradicated that in fact it
still exists out there and the empty
hand and the gentry had been feeding on
it after all this time in order to
bolster their power in order to make
them more capable now that was a story
that kind of or at least that's a set of
events that kind of goes into the
multiversity storyline which is
basically the gentry as agents of the
empty hand are quite capable of
destroying entire realities which really
beg the question how powerful is empty
hand and by extension how powerful is
the great darkness that kind of a thing
it's one of those instances and one of
those situations that dc is really
expanding on in real time as we cover
the story where there are a whole host
of multiverses that all make up the
greater omniverse and the great darkness
sits above it all alongside the presence
and the empty hand is capable of
destroying entire realities and even
whole multiverses so it's kind of nuts
exactly what role empty hand is going to
play we'll see as we get forward as we
move forward into this story uh but
regardless it's one of those things
where this is quite literally the bigger
threat the greater threat here is the
great darkness the antithesis of god the
opposite of the presence in dc comics so
if those of you guys who are coming from
marvel imagine that instead of the one
below all just being an answer to the
question what happens when the one above
all hooks out that the one below all was
actually an evil version of the one
above all and that's what you're seeing
here in dc comics with the great
darkness it's the easiest way to explain
it it's the most easily understood way
to comprehend what goes on with the
great darkness but the long and short of
this is i would imagine over the course
of this we'll end up seeing massive
expansions and massive changes to the dc
landscape as a result of that because
what a lot of people are really looking
at this as being is a lot of people a
lot of dc fans are looking at this from
the perspective of simply saying okay so
imagine if like the entire death metal
event never happened and imagine if
there were no other crisis events if
there was no infinite crisis and final
crisis or anything like that imagine
this as being a direct sequel to the
events of crisis on infinite earth
that's kind of how it's being built and
that's how people are looking at it and
that's the best way to view it so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end make sure you guys check
out the playlist for dark crisis which
again has infinite frontier and we will
cover the rest like everything else that
we cover as part of dark crisis will go
in there so you can make sure you're on
the up and up with everything that's
happening it'll all make sense
and i will catch you all later
peace